hey everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
I am once again inspired here at 11 p.m.
Eastern Time a big shout out to my wife
Liz evey who allowed me to do this not
only that kind of pushed me to do it she
believed in this thought and I thought
it was exciting I just twittered
something out and that's where I'm going
with this which is the big debate that
I'm willing to raise right now and I'm
asking a lot of people which is that is
Twitter quickly stealing an enormous
amount of Facebook and at the end of the
day a better and bigger app something
that people would find preposterous is
now starting to look very real to me the
quickness of Twitter is such a factor
the instant gratification the world is
moving so quickly that the fact that we
can get that response so quickly look
look
AOL it's the message are still around
and strong right so is Twitter taking a
lot from Facebook I noticed a lot of
people I kind of asked you know is that
the case for you and a lot of people
saying yes a lot now why is this now
some people are saying you know no
zombie invites and all the distracting
situations a lot of people saying
Facebook seems real slow to them right
now now before you get completely
ridiculous before I make this
preposterous statement let's be honest
Facebook has feeds right they've got a
lot of money right they've got up
noxious talent big shout-out to Dave
Morin follow him at at Dave Morin on
Twitter they need to figure out how to
make their feed mcmechen ism a Twitter
Club you know like flat-out
they need to figure out how to make
their feed situation a subset of
Facebook some that's quicker better more
instantaneous and we need to be adding
each other on Facebook or I think
Twitter and things like Twitter are
really going to start taking more and
more and more of the market share as
mobile becomes far more important
simplicity is going to be important and
I think the simplicity of Twitter's
mobile application is is dominant I
don't know this is really you know
kind of hit me as I was dealing with it
once you get on that speed of what
Twitter does and that allows you to
interact quickly and more efficiently
and that's really what we want I mean oh
we love to play Scrabble and there's a
lot of things we like to do and there's
definitely that place to go but that's
kind of like going on vacation do you
understand what I'm saying we spend a
little bit more money on our house than
we do one of our vacations so it's just
an amazing time where things seem and
can come from anywhere and in others
were off the big hi of South by and
Twitter always gets a big push from
there but I think as Twitter starts
getting into mainstream world because
don't get it twisted nobody knows what
Twitter is we do you're watching right
now you do but most people don't as it
starts seeping into mainstream I think
we're gonna see a real opportunity for
this app to have far more potential
pickups to have I mean him and his crew
those guys were killing it every time it
feels like even oh do what they saw
before come on let's be honest they
killed it
so my question I'm asking you tonight is
is Twitter or something like Twitter
over next 5 or 10 years and that's being
ridiculous over the next 24 to 36 months
have more upside and more importantly
are you like me and you fully expect
Facebook to adjust to this changing
scenario because it's always changing
changing scenario and adjusting their
feed mechanism to look and act and feel
a lot more like the Twitter experience
see you later I'm gonna kick you some
more knowledge this garyvaynerchuk.com
stuff we're just not gonna quit uh-huh
like P Diddy and Biggie when I quit